[Music]
why does the cartoon version of the
house and the logo look so different
from the actual house it's a beautiful
house use that for your stencil why yes
this obviously well-off family with
1,600 kids has overdone it on the
Christmas lights thanks for noticing
McAllister's put lights on the trees
across the sidewalk surely prompting
lawsuits from the dozens of kids
dripping on the wires look I know it's
chaotic and all but you're telling me
not one of these kids are paying
attention to the uniformed police
officer in the middle of the entryway
did you by any chance pick up with a
voltage adapter thing no I didn't have
time to do that how am I supposed to
shave in France
Peter ignores thousands of years of
men's shaving with alternatives to
electric razors pick up those micro
machines that are all over in there
holy hell a film shoutout to micro
machines whose commercials are on record
as being one-third the inspiration for
cinemasins doop sends off your cactus
suitcase who the hell would let an
eight-year-old pack his own suitcase if
I did that when I was eight years old it
would have been full of only red vines
and comic books also Kevin later fakes a
giant Christmas party and creates a
torturous series of traps in his house
but packing a suitcase is just too
overwhelming well kids no parents
probably a fancy orphanage harry forgets
that he just saw a full-fledged adult
walk by and ignore him two minutes ago
you at the French call Liz incompetent
Angela clearly got ahold of an English
to French translation book but this is
the best insult she could come up with
she has something to drink he's gonna
wet the bed everyone is giving this poor
kid a massive amount of motivation to
wish to spend Christmas alone this
family makes the Tenenbaums look like
the severs this is an orgy of evidence
that this is a boy's room from the 90s
Michael Jordan poster check random
sports equipment plays perfectly on
shelf got it
poster of bikini babe definitely time of
your life board game you bet wait what
is it sure that French babes still
shaved up it's Sarah seest also is buzz
worried about he's 14 years old looks
like bit tannins a nerdy little brother
I don't think he'll be getting any
during his French holiday check it out
oh man Marley buzz who's window faces
Marley's house is fascinated to see a
dude that he's presumably noticed a
million times since living here because
we needed a quick way to introduce him
also you did not notice this from the
far side of the room no your soul family
half the people on this block how come
the cops don't arrest him no enough
evidence to keep it I realize this is 14
year old logic but do they really
believe this asshole killed his family
and half the block but there wasn't
enough evidence for conviction was
Johnny Cochran involved in this case
not only is this reckless driving it'll
definitely lead to the pizza toppings
getting all shifted to one side and then
there's a cheeseless side and everyone
suffers because this asshole didn't
notice a stop sign
little Nero's must have the fastest
pizza oven ever or at least pre make
pies with every possible topping
combination and make this arbitrary 20
minute self-imposed deadline also how
big can that delivery zone be like a
half mile or less from the parking lot
and while we have automatic timers for
our lights locks for our doors that's
about as well as anybody can do these
days right dude house alarm systems have
been around since the 1870s and you can
clearly afford one so that is not the
best you can do even in 1990 buzz is
cramming this mouth like a Neanderthal
here but a second later is eating pizza
like a normal human being
anyone order me plain cheese oh yeah we
did laughs you want a somebody's gonna
have to barf it all up cuz it's gone
what I had an older brother in real life
and he did plenty of older brother
things to me but even he thinks this
movie's older brother is about three
steps too far I'm starting to think that
fuller is going to pee on Kevin
intentionally which may be early signs
of Euro philia yeah it's a dick moon for
Kevin to tackle bus but why the hell
would they leave the tickets and
passports out on the counter right next
to all the milk these people deserve the
heartache of a missing child even though
Kevin's dad is concerned about the
safety of the plane tickets he
immediately discards one of the tickets
that just happens to be Kevin's at this
point I'm starting to think they
actively want to lose this kid
um still pizza most if not all the pizza
was unharmed by the spilled milk that
everyone freaked out over rather than
take the opportunity to come back to the
kitchen in case more the house harry is
apparently hanging out and shooting this
with the pizza guy at the entrance nice
tip thanks a lot thanks somewhere deep
in the Internet there must be some
erotic fan fiction about Kevin's mom and
the pizza delivery dude but I will not
ruin my childhood by googling it you pee
all over me fine we'll put him somewhere
else
Kevin's last-ditch attempt to avoid
being peed on is the main reason he's
forgotten in the morning McAllister's
elect to use their most terrifying santa
as the one that greets you at the front
door
this clock literally has battery backup
written on it but goes off immediately
when the power is knocked out set a
chair the transporter knocks repeatedly
on the door waking no one before decided
to try the much more effective doorbell
okay I'm willing to believe the power
outage would have led the parents to
oversleep but there are 15 people in
this house not one of them is a light
sleeper or an early riser
how fast is this thing go we needed
something besides sped up McCallister's
getting ready footage to cut to so they
went with this knock hilarious nosy
neighbor kit
Bravo movie the kid from across the
street doesn't get home alone by his
even though he's left the house maybe
his parents actually care about it why
to allow you buzz don't be a moron 9 10
11 Heather did actually come up with the
right number of kids but counts herself
at number 3 and again at the end in
addition to the Murphy kid I'm surprised
Heather stellar counting skills didn't
lead to more kids being left behind
there's a huge amount of things to go
just perfectly for Kevin to be left
including the ability of all 11 kids to
utterly ignore this kid that's
announcing himself loudly by saying good
bye to them there's no way on earth
we're gonna make this plain it leaves in
45 minutes Frank's an asshole but he's
right even with no traffic it'll still
take at least 30 minutes to get from
Winnetka to O'Hare and they are trying
to make an international flight with 15
people did you count heads yes she did
instead of counting faces she counted
heads leading to this entire movies
events amid heavy holiday hustle and
bustle the giant-ass McAllister clan is
able to run right through O'Hare Airport
without being slow flight counter woman
let's all the family members on the
plane without even glancing at their
tickets hope we didn't forget anything
Kevin apparently got into mom's valium
supply last night to be able to sleep
through the commotion of 14 raucous
people getting ready at the same time
American Airlines this movie is simply
expert at taking us through the whole
house and showing the props that Kevin
will later use
like the mannequin parts dammit I'm
taking us in off to celebrate this
awesomeness cars yourself you didn't go
to the airport kids somehow didn't know
about the airport shuttles fine whatever
he's young but thinking the entire
extended family could fit in these two
cars that's a bad one Kevin unknowingly
ingests a heavy stimulant and spends the
next several minutes tripping balls what
teenage boy keeps his porno mags right
at the top of his footlocker your mom
will totally find that hide it under
your filthy mattress like everyone else
future psychopath Kevin McCallister
stages a mass execution of beloved
sports figures what else can we be
forgetting Kevin's mom gets a lot of
blame for being a crappy parent which is
fair but let's not forget his dad it's
only 12:30 p.m. Central Time and they
probably only just flown over New York
but it's pitch dark outside this plane
because movie fur gets out of time so
okay there's no way in hell that Kevin
would be able to get from the top of the
stairs and out the front door without
stopping at the bottom of the staircase
because he would just hit the floor but
even if that didn't stop him he would
run into a wall because the staircase
isn't in line with the door but even if
that didn't stop him he wouldn't get any
air coming out of the house because
there's nothing to lift him up when he
got to the first floor all in all this
is some serious bullsh
okay asking this question kind of
answers it to number 664 number 672
671 now forget this robbers knowledge of
the neighborhood much more interested in
why these three neighbors all have their
outside lights time to come on 15
seconds apart from each other it's
almost like they knew someone would
later be narrating and timing their turn
on this wait up in car door wakes Kevin
up here but he couldn't hear his entire
family leaving this morning while Harry
and Marv have a bad habit of x+ near
windows kevin had to have supersonic
hearing to be able to tell what they
said this is the third time I've been
tempted to remove a sin just for John
Williams amazing score there are at
least three themes that are all badass
and it's for a Christmas comedy I'm
getting in kate harasses this one poor
french lady when there's an entire bank
of phones that could be stalking
American woman steps off plane in Paris
and puts American coin into pay phone
and guess what it works Kevin was just
looking all around when he was
announcing he wasn't afraid anymore
but somehow missed the old scary looking
man until it was comedic ly relevant
also if old man Marley was out about
since he lives next door shouldn't have
seen Harry and Marv just a few minutes
ago we eventually know Marley's a nice
guy and all but for now he'll just stand
there in silence terrifying a young boy
the memories of Kevin's horrific screams
will make him chuckle himself to sleep
that night Kevin screams so loud he
breaks the fourth wall didn't get
anybody I'm sorry Kate nothing but a
bunch answering machines if the phone
lines are down in their neighborhood how
was Leslie able to get to their
answering machines there's no one home
the house looks secure this asshole says
the house is secure
even though Kevin didn't lock the door
as he was running away from Marley
smells fishy this cop must be on cell
maroney's payroll or something what
clock was Chris Columbus using its 8:03
p.m. in Chicago when the cop comes over
which would be 3:00 a.m. Paris time but
it's broad ass daylight out here
emboldened woman gets out of the ticket
this officer was writing goes on a
vicious crime spree for the next seven
days we're the Wet Bandits yes shake you
know that really see ransacking
someone's entire house is okay but
clogging their drains and leaving their
water running makes Harry sick sad no he
looked at me weird why would you run
well for a while you guys are acting
like you're about to abduct him maybe
one the church not calling it instead of
actually going into the church which is
much safer and requires less subterfuge
Kevin somehow finds an unused cloak and
uses that to ha
so we can see how clever he is I love
the attention to detail Kevin put into
the mannequins but is it really
necessary to put actual cards and poker
chips in front of them
Kevin had no idea when Harry and Marv
would be back right so he's been
puppeteering this Christmas party all
night in anticipation of their arrival I
admire his stamina but I don't know if
he can keep the charade up all night
long
given he'll have no idea if they drove
by or not you live in the most boring
Street in the United States of America
says the kid who claims a serial killer
lives next door
he took kid runs off thinking he's
getting shot at and never calls the cops
about the crazy man with the Tommy gun
that lives in the McCallister house it's
awesome that Kevin's adjusted to life on
his own and all but why would you have
this much laundry after two days by
himself right now looks like there's
nobody home last night the place is
jumping maybe everyone's hungover Harry
and can you keep it down earlier Kevin
decided to open the pack of firecrackers
he found in Buzz's root and put them in
this kitchen drawer because his ability
to predict what these burglars will do
was basically at a supernatural level
the kids there the parents got to be
he's home alone roll credits also on
what basis does Harry make this
assumption he saw a big party last night
and the lights came on when they tried
to break in the night before just
because he's seen this kid twice without
parents he knows he's by himself
welcome back about 9 o'clock luckily
Harry will loudly proclaim his plan for
all to hear and Kevin will happen to
open a goddamn window to listen to it
Jesus if we must have inspired the bull
that obi-wan what this is an attack of
the clowns forcible Claire netting you
can say alone when you see me and you
can stop being scary bastard how you
feel about your family is a complicated
thing rather than inquire as to why an
eight-year-old is wandering around on
Christmas Eve and attempting to help
Marly launches into his own bull sob
story basement you liked it
that's basement I don't care how mad I
was I talked to my dad especially around
the holidays except for that time that I
wish my entire family away other than
that totally open communication Kevin
cuts this extremely close waiting until
8:00 p.m. before even starting his plan
to horribly mutilated Harry also the
scheme heavily depends on two delinquent
burglars being perfectly punctual these
automatic lights are just coming on now
at 8:00 p.m. well after dark but earlier
Harry called them out as coming on well
before Kevin hid under the bed at 7:48
this is my house I have to defend sure
but you could also just call the goddamn
cops as soon as the robber show up
rather than design a saw like torture
house not only did Kevin have time to
develop this pain map in less than one
hour he found time to colorize it water
is poured on the sidewalk but Kevin is
out here in just a sweater so tightly
likely this would freeze in time for
Harry and Martha Sheila I know I'm
hammering this home but seriously this
in preparation would take days not an
hour Jesus Christ he's brought a zip
line from the house to the tree that we
later see can hold two grown men I had
to have taken at least 32 minutes and
he's doing all this other boat what he's
got time for mac and cheese now bull no
way all that it was done with three
minutes to spare
idiot kid tries to eat mac and cheese
with a knife and fork why did the
McCallister's have a doggy door there's
no mention of a dog or cat throughout
this entire movie is its sole purpose
shooting bad guys in the crotch with
biddies Oh at this point the burglar
should call the cops on this psychotic
little bastard that openly rejoices
after shooting people in the face also a
premature celebration and this has been
Joe Pesci stunt doubles physical comedy
hour thanks for coming join us next week
for the Harrison Ford news stand in
special Kevin's Macau prediction relies
not only on the fact that Marv would
pull this chain even though there's a
light on behind him but that he would be
incapable of getting out of the way of
the slowly falling iron it should be
noted that Harry is breaking and
entering in full view of the rest of the
block which we've seen has several
parties going on you're telling me no
one's outside on a smoke break and
notice the bad dude trying to break into
the nice house
Harry puts his hand on the doorknob
sideways but when we see his hand after
shoving it in the snow the M is upright
and not turning 90 degrees to the left
not only does this not burn the house
down why the McCallister's have an
antique blowtorch and it works it's too
late for you kid we're already in the
house we're gonna get you okay can't get
me like you've probably served hard time
and maybe even kill people before but
wait till you witness the power of my
feather fan kevin has a fascination with
feet but the angry kind he's kind of
like the bizarro Quentin Tarantino you
guys give up oh yeah thirsty for more
Kevin McCallister could've called the
cops several minutes ago but would like
to enact a few more acts of torment onto
these wretched bastards tomorrow royal
who makes a hilariously specific threat
like this
Kevin turns this impeccably designed
unholy house of pain into a damn
footrace at the end got about a
tarantula ex machina hey guys had Kevin
just run to the Murphy's house and left
Marv and Harry up on the rope he'd have
avoided in a dramatics when he got there
but know this little asshole knows no
mercy Jesus how long does it take these
cops to respond since Kevin called them
we've been through the spider scene the
treehouse thing the rope gag ran across
the street through the capture and
liberation of Kevin and now he's back
home imagine it
were real emergency years we have
yourself a merry little Christmas
playing during emotional moment cliche
also we never see Kevin's actual bedroom
he's been sleeping in his parents room
this whole time given how much everyone
hated him at the beginning of the movie
and started I think his parents didn't
give him one that's ok keV you can
soothe your crushing disappointment by
reliving all the carnage you inflicted
last night wait you're telling me he
cleaned up everything from last night's
rampage no micromachines feathers paint
cans or broken Christmas ornaments
anywhere Jesus that's even more chilling
keV
it's pretty cool as you didn't burn the
place down
it really is considering that whole blow
torch thing how did you guys get home oh
we took the morning flight remember the
one you didn't want to wait for and
we've arrived 30 seconds after your
arduous journey but instead of riding in
a polka van we ate shrimp in Paris ha ha
dumbass Merry Christmas
no kidding funny guy Peter regards his
youngest child in the same bum used
Manor as one would regard an
entertaining waiter at Olive Garden and
then after moving heaven and earth to
get home to Kevin he is immediately
abandoned again yeah what a nightmare
I'm sure nothing like this will ever
happen again
I'm sorry French fries and franch
dressing and franch bread see you the
boyfriend I know she's got a boyfriend
are you gonna kill me snakes snakes
snakes I don't know no snakes
Bush read sign
lemonade read it delicious cookie
googleman yeah this is this ring a bell
I'm not wearing underwear
Balch I'll show you kid crack-shot at
this